welcome back to another episode of the
recruitment mentors podcast I'm your
host his and on this week's episode I
was joined by Hayley still who after
working at the hydrogen group for nearly
12 years this year became the CEO this
was a fascinating conversation we
discussed everything from leadership
purpose working from home and I really
got to understand Haley's mindset and
why I felt that she was able to get the
opportunities that she did she's been
able to continuously climb the ranks in
a business that no doubt will be filled
with some really great quality people
and Haley was the one that was able to
get these opportunities to become the
CEO and the Haley is someone that has
got a fantastic mindset and I am not
surprised at all as to why she's uh
being able to achieve the things that
she's been able to achieve enjoy the
episode Haley welcome to the podcast hi
thank you for having me yeah thank you
for your time really looking forward to
this as I was just saying before I asked
you the million pound question which I
always like to start with I just wanted
to always like to just give people
listening to this just some immediate
context of the journey you've been on
where you are today so feel free to sort
of correct me
um if I'm wrong on parts of this but
from what I understood in our previous
conversations you joined hydrogen as a
graduate in September 2007
um and you've been there ever since yeah
and then in the last obviously the the
sort of key piece recently is in the
last eight months you become CEO of
hydrogen group and you're now
responsible for circa 350 people across
the group and I Know Your Role is
multifaceted but you break it down to me
as business as usual projects which you
want to talk about today yeah yeah so I
think I'm really excited today to talk
to you about your journey as a CEO so
far what we've learned and just a whole
mix of other things right but well
always like to start is yeah the million
pound question something that you've
probably
fought really long and hard about I'd
like to think in your leadership roles
and these types of things but in your
opinion what characteristics and traits
do you believe make up a highly
successful or criminal consultant in
today's market let's let's start there
okay and I've thought about this I
thought about it from two angles and
just to clarify
highly successful recruitment consultant
rather than manager or leader Etc it's
about being a computer yeah okay so I
think the first one is actually being
really good listening so really good
listeners they're like asking really
good questions and really genuinely
listening to the answer because if you
don't listen when you're speaking you're
rarely learning you're mainly learning
when you're listening
um and in recruitment like the really
different the different thing to other
jobs is the thing that you're kind of
selling hasn't decided yet whether it
wants to be sold or not and you're also
um you know you've got two parties that
you've got to be working with and so
it's like so crucial if you don't
necessarily you can't also have that
like sixth sense as to what someone's
not saying you know what what kind of
you know is going on behind the scenes
so that's the first thing someone who
has really good kind of questioning but
listening skills I do think that you
need to be a people person
so I do genuinely think that you have to
like enjoy people and you have to be
curious about people like I do think
that that's important
um you have to be self-motivated it is
definitely the kind of job that is
Limitless and endless but you have to
have that like personal kind of get up
and go a motivation and want to achieve
something for yourself and then now this
is a bit of a controversial one so I
know there's a lot of debate around this
and I'm going to talk about money now I
think you can be intrinsically and
extrinsically motivated and I actually
think the people who are kind of
intrinsically motivated meaning you're
doing it for something within yourself
that really matters I actually think
those people are probably the most
successful because they're always kind
of driving themselves extrinsically
motivated it's being motivated by things
like money job title Etc
but I do think in recruitment it is a
hard job and it's a really hard job
particularly for the first couple of
years and unless there's a reason why
you would do this rather than something
which perhaps doesn't have the potential
to be as well paid I'm not sure that you
would stick with it and do it so I do
think from the money perspective there
needs to be a reason and that's not to
say that you're just a really flash
person and want loads of money but it
might be that you need to support your
family or you know that there needs to
be a reason why the potential to earn
kind of a lot of money even if it's not
absolutely medial I think probably needs
to be there yeah no I think there's some
really interesting I love the listening
piece I think some I feel like a lot of
people are long gone on the journey
without they sort of almost ask
questions and they answer them before
they even had the answer and yeah
something you have to get really good
that is something I'm always even on
this podcast listening and like just
asking something and shutting up and
it's a real skill so like there's so
much that I want to unpack here but I'm
really curious about this so how would
you describe Haley before recruitment
how do you describe that person
um
it's funny like
I mean I was
constantly losing my phone yeah yeah
yeah I'm not like a particularly I'm
very focused about certain things but
things that it's something I don't care
about but
it's almost like I feel like my brain
only holds has any much like holds
certain amount of information and the
stuff that I really want to be focused
on I'm like incredibly focused on and
the rest of stuff I can be a bit like
haphazard but what would people say if
you perform recruitment I mean I went
traveling for a year before I went into
recruit when I was at University before
that and
um when I went to University I went with
a couple of friends from school and then
I have a group of like four or five
really really close girlfriends who I've
met at Uni as well including including
those two and so I honestly think I have
never really changed too much I've
always been the kind of same person
those five people would probably know
how kind of focused and ambitious I
really am when I want to be like for
example I would never be the person like
when we're traveling to you know keep
track of how we're getting to places or
what we did I just go and have a good
time like this is great I'm experiencing
loads of stuff but now like if I have to
travel on my own yeah I totally can do
kind of all of that stuff but um I don't
think I've changed huge during this
journey and that's partly because like
my core kind of group of friends is
still the same people that I was at
school with and so like yeah they've
kept me kind of exactly the same if I
suddenly changed or reinvented myself
like what is this who are you yeah so so
I was obviously just speaking to you
about this before but I I wanted to ask
it to you so you graduated with a degree
in law yep you do that because you want
to go into law in my view or not is that
no I didn't I did okay I had good
um results from school and they said
either do medicine or do law and I was
like I'm really scared of blood and I
don't want to cut off a dead body to
begin with so I guess I'll do law
because I didn't really know what I
wanted to do and law is a very kind of
broad degree which
kind of stands you in good stead or
that's kind of how I perceived it to be
so yeah I did Laura at eye level and
then but I just felt I don't know my
perception of it so thank you for
sharing that was just like that is quite
specific do you know what I mean but I'm
sure yeah it will be very respected by
employees if yeah degree in law so I I
wanted to ask you right so I was reading
an article on the way in today where
like tuition fees could rise to like 24
Grand a year right so I was really
curious to get your thoughts on like
knowing the career that you've had and
you've been able to build what you've
been able to build a hydrogen and your
career recruitment would you have still
gone to University knowing that that was
that was going to happen yes because I
think it really helped form the person
that I am and it allowed me
um space and time to
learn how to live on my own learn how to
like do my washing to be fair like yeah
well like organize my life you know and
kind of make all those mistakes and
um
yeah like just have such a good time and
I'm making it sound like as you spend an
awful lot of money just have a good time
but I do think that during that period
you kind of mature in a certain way and
there is something that I think happens
there which leads to the philosophy of
what we've been doing at hygiene one of
my philosophies which is
you know in
in school it's very structured quite
often in University there's this big
shift where you're told right here is a
timetable so here's some lectures that
you need to go to here's some tutorials
that you need to go to but at the end of
the day
choose if you want to write a
dissertation or you can do kind of other
exams and
um get yourself organized so that you
pass these exams right at this decision
but you're not told like what hours to
start what hours to finish exactly how
to organize yourself and I think that
journey of actually going from being
kind of put in this very structured
environment at school to less of a
stretched environment where you have to
think for yourself and actually get
yourself organized to kind of produce
results
it's actually quite an important
transition and that's why um so
something I um introduced within in the
business in 2019 was
um a concept called I own my time
um and it basically meant that we took
away kind of the working hours and we
took away having to work from the office
you could work whenever kind of wherever
you want and we judge the results uh
judge the business on kind of the
results rather than the inputs because I
was like you know why have we taken
people from school let them go to
university or given them time to kind of
grow up and then treat them like
children again put them in this like
nine to five and the ultimate thing that
happens is people act like children if
you teach them about you know if you
treat them like children and if you run
a business full of like rules and
regulations and this is exactly what you
want this is what you have to do this is
blah blah blah then all you ever find
out about people is whether they can
follow the rules if you take away the
rules but give them the ethos of what
we're trying to achieve and why
then you understand whether that person
um has perhaps what it takes to be
successful and you know who to invest
your time in
etc etc no thank you sharing that I
think I think that's a really
really interesting way to look at and I
had that written down the round that I
am one time so I'm definitely gonna but
that said we do hire people who don't go
to university and
um I I don't think for everyone it's
totally essential everyone and that's
really something that I'm really focused
on as well everyone has their own paths
and everyone is an individual I wouldn't
treat everyone exactly the same what I
would do is if I knew you hadn't been to
University I would understand that you
perhaps need to go through that
transition with me and me as your
manager would need to kind of work on
that and help you understand like these
these are the outputs that we expect and
but how you do it and understand that
you needed to make that transition yeah
no no I really like that I think holding
yourself accountable being responsible
for yourself yeah that's that's huge so
what what I wanted to ask you then was I
know you said around like the um that
you focus like you have a certain space
to like focus on certain things and and
all of that but like a lot of people I
think outside looking in or maybe
internally will be thinking like what
has Haley done differently to other
people to sort of get the opportunities
that you have
and like I was obviously in my sort of
preparation I saw the like a recent
interview that you did with
um California Business Journal oh yeah
yeah and I think basically one of the
things that it was like sort of the
headline there where if someone was to
ask you two years ago like was being
becoming the CEO on your list of goals
you probably would have answered no it
wasn't because I'm focusing on my task
at hand so I just wanted to start with
like
what like what what do you like maybe in
the hindsight I know you're sort of
eight months in right but my insight
into like for people that have big
aspirations that want to become a CEO
they want to become a director whatever
what is it that you think you
demonstrated maybe without saying or the
things that maybe did do differently in
let's be honest in the recruitment
environment that is extremely
competitive internally externally that
you think you demonstrated
um in your environment that you think
did were maybe some of the reasons why
you got the knock on the door the
opportunity as to like Haley is this
something that you would consider would
be open to to begin with I really just
focused on my craft like I just focused
on being a really good recruiter and
that's sort of partly what I was saying
in that article which was every role
I've done I've really focused on being
the best I could possibly be in that in
that role but I have always like
been looking around me at what's going
on in the world but also kind of
um assessing how we could do things
differently if we should be doing things
differently
um I I would say that I've been like
thirsty for kind of knowledge and
experience unless thirsty for job titles
and the job titles are followed because
I've been like really keen and had
always like this real growth mindset and
um I think partly it's also speaking up
so I am not afraid to
um speak up with ideas or views opinions
I'm completely happy to be wrong you
know I think that's how I learn and you
know how I unders understand and hear
kind of other points of view Etc
um I talk about this because we do like
a CEO induction where I meet all the new
people who are joining the business I
love it's one of my favorite things to
do because I hear all the great stuff
about them
um
but yeah that's some of the some of the
things I talk to them about is like it
like half views look around you and and
have views and opinions and don't be
afraid to kind of speak up I think it's
it's part of that I do have like strong
Vision Song philosophy
um but I just don't cut corners I'll
just work really hard and you know I've
never tried to
um I've never looked at how I could do
something kind of necessarily quicker or
easier I've always just thought how can
I do it better and kind of get the best
result
um thank you I like that I really so the
you said they're like having a real
first for like knowledge and those
things rather than job titles yeah I
think yeah and really focusing on your
craft I think that's a I think that's
really useful for people and I guess
something I've always picked up on in in
these conversations be interested in
this I don't know what you think about
this but I do feel like sometimes I
don't know if you experience this in
your management career but people in
recruitment particularly they can do
things and expect to get the promotion
or expect to get the job title they
don't and then they're demotivated so I
know you said you didn't have a first
for job titles but did you make it clear
to the people that you needed to on your
journey like what do I need to do today
I am because I think sometimes people
miss that yeah you see if I didn't get a
promotion my first question wouldn't be
like looking at that person saying kind
of I deserve this I'd want to know why
what more do I need to do you know what
what am I missing what can I work on
I've never one of the things I've always
felt is I never want to be promoted if
you don't think I'm ready because if I'm
if you're promoting me into a job
which you're saying you know is at this
level and you're now going to judge me
at this level but you don't think I'm at
that level then help me understand what
I need to do to get there I don't want
to put myself in a position where I
can't do the job that you know needs to
be done and I I yeah I but there have
been times and I've said
help me understand like I genuinely
think I'm there or or if I'm not help me
and help me get the experience help me
kind of everything that's the Insight so
I'm glad you shared that because I think
some people can do things then it's like
they don't ask what that looks like and
then they go into their monthly review
or whatever and they're like what
haven't I got a promotion but they
haven't they haven't they haven't met
that person or at least ask that person
like what is it exactly that you need me
to do yeah and get that Clarity yeah you
know so I think that's what yeah take
responsibility for yourself I like I
really believe kind of
from a mental health perspective one of
the really most important things I think
is
it's not just about taking
responsibility of yourself but if you if
you don't do that it's like handing over
the keys to someone else for your
happiness it's like saying I rely on you
and your feedback and your opinion for
me to be happy whereas if you know
you're always taking control and you're
always looking at what you can do in a
situation and what you're in control of
then you're kind of success and
happiness is in your hands rather than
someone else's and if it's in someone
else's hands you really feel quite
helpless and hopeless and that is quite
at the core of of people who do have
mental health issues and are kind of
struggling and so whenever something
happens and there have been things that
have happened to me that have been
really tough I've always tried to
reframe it and look at what can I take
from this you know what can I
um do differently how can I kind of help
myself not be in this situation again
um because otherwise if you're just a
victim or it's kind of you put too much
on someone else then you're not in
control of it anymore where's mindset
come from
not everyone has like I'm like I'm
really relate with that and like that
speaks volumes to me as well I really
believe in that like I love what you
just said there and I yeah I speak to my
friends about this a lot and these
things like You're so out of control as
you said if you're putting the keys on
someone else and yeah I just love that
so like how have you have not everyone
has this like you can't hold it tonight
people ask me this like why what course
and stuff do you listen to would you do
and actually specifically at certain
times don't listen to stuff so I can
really hear my own thoughts clearly and
get really clear on what I'm doing what
my vision is what I really believe in
um I mean a fair bit comes from my mum
my mum is naturally like this she's like
a really inspirational person and
um she she naturally reframes things
she's just real really positive and
um I I don't know from your mum that's
that's amazing like we've never yeah I
guess we'll set you down and gone like
this is how you this is they do work in
they work in sport they don't work in um
business which maybe helps in some ways
it's a lot you can learn from it but
yeah I guess you've taken in to actually
reframed things and these things that
you may look at something yeah I guess
like little little things that you can
um yeah I see her do it with my niece a
little bit sometimes she's like uh no
Connie that's you know you know look at
it this way
dude might have just kicked over that
lovely tower that you just built but
think of it this way you've got the
chance to build it again
I love that so talk to me about how how
did you feel when you got offered the
CEO position
I felt completely bewildered to be
honest with you and also I felt like
um
so to put it into perspective when I had
my baby in June
um we had to move out of a flat two
weeks later moved into another flat um
which was nowhere near my friend it was
like on the Isle of dogs and stuff and
um when we started talking about this I
went in to meet Ian and John
um and I'd had to think get my mum or
someone to look after the baby and he
must have only been about three months
old or something and so I was a bit like
and so when all of this was being taught
about with the CEO stuff I was just a
bit like
really but also like well yes I would
like to do that and yeah that's great
but it's a bit of a blur in many ways
and and it was and I and it sort of
slowly dawned on me I came home and sort
of said to my husband heck she won't
believe this like I might actually be
going back as CEO and he was like
wow it sounds a bit like yeah wow and
then just kind of carried on being a mum
with this tiny baby that I was kind of
struggling to work out how to navigate
um so there was like quite a period
where I knew about it and no one else
knew about it
um and so I had quite a long time to get
used to the idea but also yeah you're
ready for it yeah but strangely enough
it's felt like the most natural
transition of any of the jobs
that I've done yeah a lot of people and
I don't know whether that's because I
had the baby so
um I had six months maternity leave but
then when I came back in January I came
back as CEO and it just felt um I don't
know it felt really natural a lot of
people like we nervous going back to
work I was like no I was totally
relieved because I did not enjoy being
on maternity leave
um and no I was relieved and it just
felt like
quite a natural transition strangely so
I have I think this is the right time to
ask ask this with what you just shared
with us so I've done multiple sort of
women recruitment series and and these
types of things and from my perspective
from sitting down with successful women
in recruitment like one of the things
I've always picked up on is they can
they can often find themselves arriving
at this sort of destination in their
life where it's like do I carry on
putting energy and time into career or
pull it into family and raising a family
and having a family and I do feel like
from my perception again recruiting has
massively evolved but I think a lot of
the older women that I've sat down with
that was a really difficult time for
them particularly being in a recruitment
context so I wanted to ask you again
I'll pick this up in a sort of interview
that you said
um and this might just just help people
with the um on a similar journey and to
you and and what I picked up on was you
said you didn't meet your husband until
he was in your 30s
um so maybe a long like a longer time
than like the perceived time ready to
meet the person you're meant to be we're
right and you you said I didn't I I
didn't dare to dream that I might get
the opportunity to have a baby yeah so
like I just wanted to just for you to
just share if you're happy to like how
how did you how did you make sure that I
didn't like I used the word [ __ ] you
but I don't want that to be too extreme
you know what I mean like that that's a
lot of like a pressure potentially you
could put on yourself like am I going to
be able to have a child these things
whilst they're never getting a career
and being successful like how how did
you even if you felt like that how did
you make sure that I didn't take over
and then but the desire maybe you'd have
a baby yeah like you may even thought it
never would have happened well it's so
much pressure for yeah but it goes back
to that feeling of looking at the things
that you are in control of so
um I wasn't in control of whether I was
going to have a baby or not because I
definitely wasn't gonna have a baby with
just anyone I knew that I prefer not I
prefer not to have a baby and have it
with the wrong person so take it very
seriously I I think that's the biggest
most important choice I've made in my
life who's gonna to be the father of my
son because he has to live forever so
um
hey everyone a real quick one from me
this podcast would not be possible
without our amazing podcast Partners Vin
cherry and saucebreaker because you
listen to this podcast you were able to
get your hands on exclusive savings on
both of these award-winning products if
you're a growing recruitment business
you have to check out vinceri who are an
all-in-one operating system for your
growing recruitment business with Source
breaker if you want to make sure that
all of your recruiters have the best
tools on the market to stand out and
beat their competition then you have to
check out Source breaker use the link in
the show notes in the comments below and
you'll be able to get yourself exclusive
savings on these amazing products yeah
yeah I mean I I looked at it and I
thought
do you know what I have a career that I
love I love being in Recruitment and
um I love all my friends in my team and
genuinely
um you know it almost worried me the
opposite that I would never get round to
meeting anyone because I'm so like busy
with my job and loving it so much but
again like
that's the kind of thing that if you
frame it in a way that
I want to have a baby and
um maybe I need to put everything on
hold to try and make that happen it's
quite a difficult thing to force to
happen and so I felt actually the
opposite work on everything else in my
life so work towards making sure I kind
of brought my flat and I'd got to where
I wanted to do with my job and you know
my other interests or seeing friends
exercising all that kind of stuff focus
on the things that I am in control of
um and yeah keep going out and trying to
meet people but
um I never wanted to look back and feel
like I'd wasted that time so I kind of
held a deep down hope or believe that
Adventure I would meet someone that I
wanted to be with
um and I just never wanted I remember
saying this my friend on a dog walk once
when we were both single and saying I'm
really worried that you know we are
worried that we're single and we're not
going to meet someone but
um once it then happens I don't want us
to look back on this period and think we
wasted it by worrying or kind of you
know prioritizing that too much because
even if it doesn't happen you know
you've still got that life to live as it
is so
um I think that that didn't I didn't let
that kind of weigh on me too heavily
although obviously is it's on your mind
but I just felt like what would be would
be with that and I would live my life in
the best possible way giving myself like
the best variety the best experiences I
could say I felt as fulfilled as I
couldn't if that came along then that's
amazing but if it wasn't meant to be for
me and that wasn't kind of my my
destination thanks for sharing that I
think that would be really helpful for
people to like it's hard though like you
say these things
I understand I get it it is really hard
and some people possibly feel more
maternal than I did I didn't feel like I
was put on this Earth I need to be a
mother but I know some people feel much
more strongly about that than perhaps I
did ah thank you for sharing that so let
so you had a couple of car even though
you obviously use he was processing
being a mum yeah and there's no rule
book on that right you got told that
yeah come back as a CEO she had a couple
of months to sort of I guess yeah digest
it process yeah what was like I'll just
be Keen to hear like what was Haley's
internal strategy of like this is how
I'm going to approach being a CEO for
the first time again there's no rule
book or I don't know you like what what
was the internal the internal dialogue
of life this is what I'm going to make
sure I am this is what I'm going to
avoid how how is you yeah I got into
January I don't have that I'd just be
myself and I just go with my instincts
and I think that's one of the things
that has stood me in really good stead I
don't so I can guess myself and I don't
I'm really instinctive about what I do
so it means that
um rightly or wrongly perhaps um that I
don't that I don't sit and think for a
long time I just know kind of know where
I am and I I really believe that I I
Believe In My Philosophy to
um building teams running businesses I
believe it's good and strong and and I
also feel confident in my team and the
people around me one thing I did do when
I went back was look very carefully at
the kind of support that I had in place
so
um I said to John and Ian if I'm gonna
do this a couple of things one I don't
want to travel constantly I will travel
a bit but I don't want to travel kind of
all the time and I so that's one thing
also
um like I have a PA but also some of
what she does it supports me from a
personal angle as well
um because that's some of the kind of
Pinchy stuff that sometimes when you're
really busy you know as a mum yeah yeah
and sometimes like my husband that is
not his domain some of that stuff and
you have to be realistic about what
people can and can't do and you know I
know he's not um
like he doesn't love personal happiness
I wouldn't ask him to do it necessarily
and but then also at work making sure
that you've got the right support
mechanisms in place and
um when I went into it no I just was I
just thought like be yourself but also
remember I'd been out of the business
for six months so I went into it
thinking just listen and learn and in a
weird way it was quite a nice transition
and quite easy for me because I could be
like I'm coming at this from quite a
distance which is what you need to do as
a CEO anyway you need to have that kind
of distance so you can keep your eye on
directional travel and strategy
and um
yeah it meant that
I kind of naturally had that distance
and I could just be listening and asking
questions kind of legit because I've
been there rather than suddenly
switching from being like in the kind of
detail doing that yeah it was like it
almost made it sort of easier I guess
coming at it from having been I think
that's great so what
what's been maybe like the most
challenging so far that you least
expected I know you said you just went
into it you brought your full self there
you listen and learn and like in
hindsight I know where eight months in
we're still in the thick of it here but
I know what do you think yeah like one
thing I really didn't expect and I have
felt and this might be potentially more
of a commentary on me than the the
reality of what's going on but
um I have always been like as I am I
don't really think of myself as a CEO I
don't think of myself as particularly
senior I just am who I am and like I
love people I love all the people in my
business I feel really strongly kind of
about that
um but you definitely don't see me in
suits like what I'm wearing today is the
kind of stuff I wear I always wear
trainers like or Doc Martens or
something you know like I'm definitely
not
stereotypically what you might expect as
a CEO particularly perhaps in you know
Professional Services type sector and
that's never bothered me in the
slightest I've always just been kind of
like yeah just just I'm who I am but I
feel it's been I felt more pressure
since I've had the title to be something
that other people want me to be and I
can see it can sometimes make them
uncomfortable that they're not quite
sure
how to kind of navigate it and um but I
think that that is in some instances a
commentary on the um where we're at in
the world generally like I think there's
a real moment for women I think women
are having a particular moment where you
know the skills that we have as females
and can lean into potentially more
easily than mencan although that's not
to say that men don't have these skills
I definitely think they do but some of
those are
perhaps valued more now than they ever
have been before
um and I think there's just a shift this
like because what I don't believe in is
the control and command type like I'm
the CEO so you do what I say like I
believe I'm the CEO so I work for you
guys so talk to me tell me who are you
what are you doing why are you doing it
let me learn let me understand and then
let me step back and see how I guide the
business with all that kind of in mind
and let me work as hard as possible for
you all
um and I and yeah I feel that more than
I thought I would or the the um I had
previously and I found myself from times
so I've been like oh should I wear this
really yeah I love you wearing this yeah
yeah but then sometimes I I can go a bit
off peace and probably should be
thinking that anyway regardless
I love that so let's just let's just get
into like hydrogen in the business the
group like I think a lot of people the
list of the show are recruiting
entrepreneurs yeah I think yeah there
will be a few sort of interesting things
here that I think people would be
curious about so one of the things maybe
we could start with like we mentioned in
terms of the group Circa 350 people uh
within the group like how does a company
of of that size like
protect its cultural standards I'm just
super interested in that yeah that is
really interesting
um
we're doing a lot of work on that at the
moment and I would say I think we've
been on a journey with our culture and
actually that's partly why I think I'm
in this role because that is something I
really care about and I believe in and
get the culture right and the figures
will look after themselves
um and we're actually just the first
thing that I've been doing is working on
our purpose so
um we talk a lot a few things like oh my
future know my time about like the ethos
and and this ethos is really to do with
um
Freedom of Choice freedom of thinking
accountability for people
um and and
it's it's a bit of a red herring the
working from home or not people often
think it's just about that and it's not
about that it's about you know again
like taking away the rules and letting
people think freely and then helping to
kind of shape them
um
and so we've been talking a lot about
that and I've got to the point where we
thought we need actually to kind of
distill down exactly what we're saying
here and how we how we're going to
articulate it and use it to help kind of
govern decisions that we're making and
you know the direction of the business
so we've been really
um defining what our purpose is and
we're just kind of launching it into the
business at the moment and we're doing
loads and loads of work on it and
um that I think is a really key thing to
make sure that you've got right you're
all you're all focusing on the right
thing and
um
sort of singing from the same hymn sheet
I suppose and
anyone who doesn't if you're very clear
about what it is you believe in and what
you believe in as a business then I
think the people who believe in it too
stay stay and engage with you engage
with the business the people who don't
tend to leave but that's that's kind of
okay
if if you truly yeah if you truly do
believe it yourself and you have got the
right so on that that's really
interesting so on the purpose piece
how like how involved do you how
involved do you get the people in the
business in the creation of that we so
yeah it's interesting so we had an
agency who helped us with it so they
don't come in that the agency don't come
in and say like CEO I'm going to tell
you no no no they well in a way they do
they don't say we're going to tell you
what your purpose is they say let's talk
to you and find out so talk to like
obviously all of the exec Etc but we
also got over 60 people in the business
actually it's more like 90 in the end
involved in it through Innovation teams
so actually really and that we were very
clear with them this has to come from
the business it's not just coming from
me
um but you do ultimately need someone
with vision and again I think that's
really important for the role of a CEO
like you do need to have Vision be able
to look to the Future have something
that you kind of really believe in
um and so yeah you get you have to get
everybody involved you know you have to
kind of understand what is already
within the business what they're feeling
Etc as well so so let's talk about this
I own I own my time initiative right so
you said you launched that in 2019 you
said yeah so like let's just talk about
it just so then I think a lot of people
were interested like for me like I don't
know I'll be honest I'm sort of circus
in the sort of work from home office
sort of debate if I'm honest yeah and
like so clearly 2019 I own my time so
what I take from that is as you said
empowering people to like you said have
freedom choice to make their own
decisions as to what's best for them and
like they do what they think is going to
enable them to get to where they need to
rather than like you said that means
like you in are you in the office or not
in the office sort of thing so like as a
as a business as large as you are like
how how does hydrogen group like view
like how do you view this work from home
in the office thing like how have you
approached it because I feel like
I don't know correct if I'm wrong here
but I do feel like with the amount of
people that you're involved with that
could be even more challenging like if
I've got a business with 20 people it's
like right guys we're going to try this
this week yeah yeah after that did you
get what I mean yeah because I
personally my perception of it right now
is like
online it's very black and white which I
don't actually quite like I think a lot
of people go to sort of judging before
being curious so if you come out online
and say hydrogen five days a week in the
office everyone you have people go hey
you're wrong that's entirely wrong you
can't do it and no one says that's
interesting how did you come to that
conclusion right so how has a business
of your size navigated that because I
feel like yeah this is this is really
difficult for a lot of recruitment
owners it's really hard but you
something I really believe in is the
power of the conversation so the most
important thing is the conversation that
comes before you deciding where you're
going to work and how you're going to
work and
um I would say I learned an awful lot
rolling out that in 2019 I I would do it
differently if I did it again it and
made lots of mistakes and we're still
getting this ethos absolutely right in
the business now three years on
um because yeah that that was the
problem it was too much like
do I work from home do I work from the
office and by giving people that um
flexibility it left the managers in kind
of a place where they were like hang on
so are you saying I can't tell people
what to do or that what what is my role
in this situation if you're saying
everyone's got freedom everyone must
make their own choices to do what they
want
um and that's actually still something I
think that's one of the biggest things
in the industry at the moment like you
know with this debate the real crucial
thing is the way that I want us to run
the business and the way that we are
running the business
um is very much a different different to
how I was brought up now so I was very
much brought up in this kind of control
and command get in at eight leave at
seven type Vibe
um and so I do understand that a lot of
managers who have also been brought up
in that way are kind of at a losses to
how to manage in this new environment
and I don't want us to be a control and
command business I want us to be a
business where we hire people who are
motivated accountable kind of bright
want to be there and we but that doesn't
mean that we don't say to them look I I
guess the best example which I get asked
all the time is around this training
thing is it better to train in person or
kind of um remotely
I would prefer to hire someone who is
going to be absolutely amazing but is
fully remote than someone who is average
but can come into the office now that
will mean the onboarding is trickier and
takes longer I do appreciate that and
there is like part of me that feels like
um you know we say oh they can't see
what I'm doing they don't learn by
osmosis there is a benefit to that but
that does also mean in some instances
people are just carrying on what they're
doing and ignoring the person next to
them that's not everyone but that that
kind of can happen and with the best
will in the world like you're incredibly
busy in recruitment when you're having
to onboard remotely you do have to stop
what you're doing and look at this
person and train them so in some
instances there are some benefits to
kind of doing it remotely but but
ultimately if that person remotely is
brilliant and is going to be
um
you know 500k biller for me in the
future then yeah I prefers to go through
the pain of it taking a bit longer kind
of onboarding remotely but the the thing
that I really feel about it is
say you're new in your grad the most
important thing to me is that I have
this conversation with you that says
um right these are your first two weeks
um you know talk to me about your setup
at home talk to me about how your life
works and what are the important kind of
pressures on you outside of work so that
we can figure out what the best working
pattern is now my advice to you would be
I actually think I'm willing to come in
for the first couple of weeks or the
first month or so I think there's a
great benefit to being in for the kind
of first month or so but after that the
best benefit is to get you to the best
place that you can be personal and
professional life so let's see how that
sort of works and have an ongoing
conversation now if I said that to you
and you said to me look I've got elderly
parents who I look after it's going to
be really difficult for me to come in
every day I totally understand that and
that's fine if you said well thanks so
much for saying that you'll come in with
me but I can't be asked then at least I
know at least I've had this conversation
I understand where you stand I
understand some of your thinking I'm
kind of engaged with where your life is
at and what's going on with you and I
can be deciding whether I want to invest
in this person whether I want to spend
my time training this person because
I've now got some understanding about
how they feel the way they operate and
what they're going to do if I'd said
right first two weeks you've got to be
in the office eight till six all I will
know is whether you can get your ass
into the office at eight and whether you
still leave at six you know it's the
conversation yeah it's around like this
conversation it's how you then end up
working I mean I personally think a good
makes it but for me I do a mix of both
and I've tried and it's taken me a long
time in these eight months to figure out
what kind of works best so just quickly
on that you said you would do things
differently if you throw that out what I
would spend more no no I would spend
more time and I still need to do it and
I'm doing it I will spend more time
helping the kind of managers understand
how to manage it right so we spoke at a
leadership level like a kind of
directors level and everyone kind of
agreed that it was going to happen one
of my issues though is with some things
when you're driving really big change in
a business if if you're not careful if
you take on too much opinion sometimes
the change can never happen and you can
run a business by committee which isn't
always great as well and I knew this was
a fairly Forward Thinking thing in 2019
bear in mind we hadn't had code with
them
um and I kind of knew there would be a
lot of pushback so in many ways as well
you kind of have to do a big bang and
then figure it out afterwards so it's a
little bit the Chicken and the Egg but I
think I would have spent a bit more time
with the kind of manager population
helping them understand more about
really what we were saying
thanks for sharing that I think that
would be really helpful for people so
curious on this I don't know how you
feel I don't know what your sort of
current thoughts are on this but a lot
of recruitment leaders that I speak to
continue to tell me that how they're
finding the market is they have started
to notice that clients are maybe
reducing um the amount they're spending
on agency spend maybe you've pulled a
particular few roles but overall they're
still got really healthy client pipeline
healthy job flow and feel mostly
depending on what sector and Optimist at
so I was just really curious like
obviously the media is a whole different
story in terms of against an economic
economic downturn recession all this how
how does a business like hydrogen with
the amount of people that you're
responsible for like what do you have
top of mind because I'm like people can
see everything that they're reading yeah
and it can get really negative really
quickly for people so yeah how what's
top of mind what do you think about what
smart decisions are we thinking about
here from from the seat that you're in
well first of all it goes back to what
you're in control of yeah again if you
focus too much on the market and it's
kind of out of people's control you can
make them feel really hopeless and
helpless and kind of make them think
it's not really worth coming to work
because the Market's so terrible but
whatever I do nothing will happen so one
I wouldn't focus on the market that much
and also you know
no one fully knows what's gonna happen
so I I've also really disliked spending
a lot of time speculating on things that
you know I really hate wasting time and
energy on stuff that could happen yeah
like in anyway and what I decide about
it well anyway yeah so there's that
element to it but from a business
perspective you sort of always have to
be planning for that kind of thing so
the important things are having a good
mix of sectors so to kind of keep
yourself like diversify have scientific
so we have like life science have
Professional Services don't just be
Overexposed to like the fs sector make
sure that you have a good range of
sectors that you're in have a good
balance between contract and perm one's
usually booming versus the other and you
know make sure you've got that good kind
of Base in contract where you know that
you've got that kind of um your contract
all coming through each month anyway and
the other thing and there's like loads
of different
um commentary on this sort of thing and
we make sure that we have a really
strong balance sheet so we don't carry
loads of debt and we're often and we
make sure that we're really conscious of
that like we're quite kind of cash rich
I suppose so we delisted when we were in
2020 we spent a lot of the money that we
had in the bank on in effect buying
ourselves back do listing
um but we make sure we build up those
reserves so we don't invest everything
that we make in terms of profits we're
in effect saving for a rainy day so you
know make sure you've got that
um the other thing and there's a lot of
debate about this as well is we don't
pay the higher salaries there will be
recruiters out there who will pay much
higher base salaries it's definitely
we try and be competitive we appreciate
that people have like their own
overheads that they have to cover and
they want an amount of guarantee about
that we do want the best people so you
know we're competitive about it but one
of the other things about
um not paying the higher salaries and
having a good portion of someone's
salary made up of the bonus is that
you're then a flexible asset so if a
recession massively hits we don't have
to get rid of everyone because naturally
we will be paying less per person
because their their bonuses will be less
so you know we're not we don't have our
hands tied in that kind of situation to
actually get rid of people what from
your perspective what do you think has
been one of the biggest mistakes hiding
a group has made
because that's interesting
um
I think
there was some really bad hiring that
went on and some we got rid of some
people who I thought were really
talented and if they were in the right
roles because I think we've let people
dictate too much what roles they want to
do rather than having people in roles
that they're really good at and that's
something we're working on now and I
think there's a lot of this in
recruitment where you have like you know
amazing Villas who are never going to be
the best managers but in recruitment
you'll often let them be and it I guess
we've let the Tail Wag the Dog in um the
past and we did some hiring which wasn't
great and
um
yeah I would never want to name names or
anything like that but yeah I would say
I would say some of that probably it's
interesting it comes back to your
culture piece and protecting that and
really owning that and yeah that also
involves if people aren't along with
that then even if there might be one of
your biggest earners oh yeah you have to
protect her yeah yeah 100
um so I guess as we sort of come towards
the end I have to ask you because of I
think a lot of people I was looking at
your post when you announced your CEO
and looking at the comments and stuff
like from your perspective I think it I
do feel like the needle has definitely
moved in a positive way but how do you
feel we can Inspire more women in in the
industry do you know what I think is so
funny about this is
like a lot of the skills which studies
say are particularly female so like
empathy listening skills
um that kind of thing are so relevant in
recruitment it blows my mind sometimes
that
you know we wouldn't have more women
recruitment but I do understand why I
mean I I definitely will do everything
that I can to inspire more women I'm
just about to in the next couple of
weeks sit down with cross-section of
women from our business who understand
really what their challenges are try and
understand different people's
perspectives my mind is only my journey
and what I felt but I think having
people in women in senior roles I think
listening
um
evolving being being you know
understanding the pressures definitely
being parents and you know I think the
men and women actually with that kind of
thing making sure that you have got a
setup which is feasible when I came into
recruitment it definitely was like you
this is not a long-term career because I
can't see anyone who's got kids or even
anyone I don't like you know no no Role
Models exactly and when I in 2019 when I
push in really hard about that and that
was because I had met my husband by then
and I knew I would want children in the
coming years and I was like I'm not
letting this derail my career I'm gonna
do something myself to make sure I've
got a setup where I can have everything
that kind of I want to do in life as
well and I think I would say to women
like it is such an amazing industry it
is it's so much fun and you know just
but but speak up take responsibility
like make yourself heard you know that's
um
you've got so much to offer no yeah I
love that so I was finished before
obviously I did reach out to Ian oh yeah
some questions there's nothing nothing
to be wary of here but I've ended up
I've ended up
creating my own question okay because of
Ian basically because I spoke to him but
anyway the question I have for you the
other ones that he asked I feel like
we've sort of covered but
the question I have for you is if I was
to ask uh Ian what you had to improve on
to become an even better SEO right now
what do you think you would say he would
say
not doing the doing because I'm a real
doer and I love to be involved in
everything and I have like my natural
desires want to do it myself rather than
like that's my kind of natural resting
place rather than as a CEO
you're not the doer anymore you're the
conductor you know you have people
playing to their position let them play
to their position you conduct it and you
make it happen he's always saying to me
stop leaving meetings with things that
you're going to do but it's partly
because I love doing stuff myself
um and he would say yeah stop doing the
doing and get better at um
you know just conducting I love that not
doing the day yeah everyone else is
probably like great I'd love to know
what was you had to do so much of that
together yeah yeah yeah I speak to so
many people
who want to do that and because they
love it so much yeah so I understand but
it's not like I guess that's the thing
it's not like saying stop working it's
like put my time energy and passion and
my like all this abundance of energy
I've got into the other things that you
do as you see yeah like I said be the
conductor I think that's yeah
well look Helly thanks so much for
joining me I think I can from our
conversation I think I've definitely for
me my perception and I think other
people listen to this will definitely be
able to see why you've why you've got to
where you've got to I think you've got
an amazing mindset I think you'll
inspire a lot of people and um thank you
so much for joining me that is very kind
of you today and I've loved it thank you
so much for having me thank you so much
for listening to the episode I hope you
enjoyed it and got value from the
conversation if you did enjoy it please
don't forget to like share and subscribe
and we'll see you in the next episode